many people think the transactions in
bitcoin are anonymous
that's wrong
they're not
they're technically what's known as
pseudonymous
and if your ability to analyze the
blockchain which remember is public and
everybody can see
you have an ability to identify
transactions on bitcoin with a level of
detail and specificity that you can't do
with for example cash
if somebody pays cash for drugs
there's no public record of the fact
that the cash moved in one direction and
the heroin moved in another
intriguingly with bitcoin you can trace
these transactions if you're
sufficiently sophisticated
want evidence of that really easy have a
look at the indictment that mueller's
office issued against the 12 russian
hackers on july 13 2018.
if you read that indictment there's very
specific information there about how the
russians paid for servers and for other
aspects of their hacking activity with
bitcoin
now how is it that mueller's office
would know that certain servers and
other services were paid for with
bitcoin
simple answer
they're able to read the blockchain
they can follow the transactions from
one wallet which has a public number to
another wallet that has another public
number and using other sources they're
able to figure out who's behind the
wallet
and they're able to figure out the names
of the people behind the wallet
simple story
if the russian hackers can't hide their
identity from mueller's office
neither can you
so
bitcoin is not really anonymous
vis-a-vis the ability of sophisticated
parties to read and to analyze the
blockchain
now clearly some people don't like that
idea so they're trying to develop
technologies that are more secure than
bitcoin in terms of providing higher
levels of anonymity
they're services like monero they're
services like zcash but it remains to be
seen as to whether those systems can be
cracked and whether they really are
anonymous or just more difficult to
interpret than bitcoin
the jury's out on that